ALLISON O'HAIR:
--previous video, we
used data in linear
regression to show
that if a team
scores at least 135
more runs than their opponent
throughout the regular season,
then we predict that that team
will win at least 95 games
and make the playoffs.
This means that we need to
know how many runs a team will
score, which we will show
can be predicted using
batting statistics, and how
many runs a team will allow,
which we will show can be
predicted using fielding
and pitching statistics.
Let's start by creating
a linear regression
model to predict runs scored.
The Oakland A's are interested
in answering the question,
how does a team score more runs?
They discovered that
two baseball statistics
were significantly more
important than anything else.
These were on-base
percentage, or OBP,
which is the percentage
of time a player gets
on base, including walks,
and slugging percentage,
or SLG, which measures how
far a player gets around
the bases on his turn and
measures the power of a hitter.
Most teams and
people in baseball
focused instead on
batting average, or BA,
which measures how
often a hitter gets
on base by hitting the ball.
This focuses on hits
instead of walks.
The Oakland A's claimed
that on-base percentage
was the most important.
Slugging percentage
was important.
And batting average
was overvalued.
Let's see if we can use
linear regression in R
to verify which
baseball statistics are
more important to predict runs.
In the previous video, we
created her dataset in R
and called it Moneyball.
Let's take a look at the
structure of our data again.
Our dataset includes
many variables including
runs scored, or RS,
on-base percentage, OBP,
slugging percentage, SLG,
and batting average, BA.
We want to see if we can use
linear regression to predict
runs scored using the
three hitting statistics,
on-base percentage, slugging
percentage, and batting
average.
So let's build a linear
regression equation using
the LM function to
predict runs scored
using the independent
variables OBP, SLG, and BA.
Our dataset is Moneyball.
If we look at the summary
of our regression equation,
we can see that all of
our independent variables
are highly significant.
And our R squared is 0.93.
If we look at our
coefficients, we
see that the coefficient for
batting average is negative.
This says that all other
things being equal,
a team with a higher batting
average will score fewer runs.
But this is a bit
counterintuitive.
What's going on here is a
case of multi-collinearity.
These three hitting statistics
are highly correlated.
So it's hard to
interpret our model.
Let's see if we can remove
batting average, the variable
with the negative coefficient
and the least significance,
to see if we can improve the
interpretability of our model.
So let's rerun our
regression equation
without the variable BA.
If we look at the summary of
our new regression equation,
we can see that our variables
are again highly significant.
The coefficients
are all positive,
as we would expect them to be.
And our R squared is now 0.9296,
or about the same as before.
So this model is simpler
with one fewer variable,
but has about the same
predictive ability
as a three variable model.
You can experiment
and see that if we
had taken out on-base percentage
or slugging percentage
instead of batting
average, our R squared
would have gone down more.
If we look at the
coefficients, we
can see that the coefficient
for on-base percentage
is significantly higher
than the coefficient
for slugging percentage.
Since these variables are
on about the same scale,
this tells us that on-base
percentage is worth more
than slugging percentage.
So using linear regression we're
able to verify the claims made
in Moneyball that batting
average is overvalued,
on-base percentage is the
most important, and slugging
percentage is important.
We can create a
very similar model
to predict runs allowed
or opponent runs.
This model uses pitching
statistics, opponents
on-base percentage, or OOBP, and
opponents slugging percentage,
or OSLG.
The statistics are
computed in the same way
as on-base percentage
and slugging percentage,
but use the actions of
the opposing batters
against our team's
pitcher and fielders.
Using our dataset in R, we can
build a linear regression model
to predict runs allowed using
opponents on-base percentage
and opponents
slugging percentage.
This is, again, a very strong
model with an R squared
value of 0.91.
And both variables
are significant.
In the next video,
we'll show how
we can apply these models
to predict whether or not
a team will make the playoffs.